what are we having photos all right
let's take a look at some top photos now
little light relief hopefully number
three well not this one Santiago Chile
capital is temporarily shut down due to
a smog quote emergency cars were ordered
off the streets businesses told to close
and seven million residents told to stay
indoors santiago's andes mountain range
allows a gray haze of pollution to get
trapped over the city it's all the fault
of andy's yeah and then Brendan you
mentioned New Delhi yesterday we were
looking at yoga photo exactly i think
one of the things we're learning is that
we used to think of smog as a beijing
problem it's not it's a developing
market it's it is a very difficult
problem to solve you have to do things
with traffic yeah do things and so at
Delhi has a huge problem I Mexico City
he has traditionally had a problem as
well yeah I look at Mexico City from our
childhood but these are new geographies
ventilation shafts through the Andes
that's what we need done yes or maybe we
need to do this cuz this is number two
yesterday afternoon while floating
somewhere over Russia astronaut scott
Kelly tweeted a picture of a red aurora
borealis exclaiming quote I've never
seen this before spectacular the
Northern Lights occur when electrons
from solar winds Tom interact with
atmospheric elements like oxygen or
nitrogen that's your lesson for the day
the color depends on which atom is
struck and at what altitude the most
common color is yellow green and it
comes from an oxygen reaction at 60
miles above the earth these ones though
are rare yes yes with vaani 200 miles
trans girl I just like spectrometry
nicely done I'm gonna move straight on
yesterday the London Bridge walking path
was covered in a mosaic of rainbow side
wall tiles the installation was designed
by artist Gemma Cairney who collaborated
with spark your city a global movement
dedicated to spark joy in everyday life
Tommy clubs are done right well they
could of course just play surveillance
in the morning and that would spark joy
in their everyday lives I mean honest
that bridge just feels like a wellness
initiative right how do you make people
feel better not through this not through
wellness initiatives fewer hours better
pay that is the solution I I don't
disagree though I wonder what Prince
Charles thinks he's been very
conservative on his architecture